There are going to be about 9.6 billion
people in the world by the year 2050.
And if you look at the way
that yields are increasing,
they're not increasing fast enough
to feed 9.6 billion people.
So while past gains in
agriculture productivity
have come from using more
water and using more land,
we're at a point where we don't
have those resources anymore.
The three common themes that matter
are controlling the environment,
measuring the environment and
analyzing what's going on.
Farm View is bringing
all that together.
Take a comprehensive view. Bring
all these technologies together.
We use robotics for controlling.
We use different types of sensor
technologies for the measurement
and often the sensors are
deployed by the robots.
And then we use machine
learning for the analysis.
We can grow more food with
less water and less land.
So one of the things
we need to do
is transfer the kinds of research
we do in the United States
to parts of the world
that really need it.
So that they can
create better crops
that then go to their
local growers.
That the growers can grow then
using their traditional methods
or however their food system
currently works.
We just give them a better plant
that makes them more productive.
Locally, there are
many small farms
that are right on the edge
of being able to survive.
And with the increase in
efficiency that we can provide
with better sensing and better
technologies they can stay in business.
When we do this kind of work,
we have to work with
experts from other fields.
Land grant universities,
government agencies,
local growers who are
producing crops.
We have a wide range of
partners that we work with
to really bring this
stuff into the field
and make sure that we're actually solving
problems that need to be solved.
Being that conduit
from these basic fundamental research
to solving real problems
is one of the big impacts that
Carnegie Mellon can have on the world.